nos piden que encontremos la raíz cúbica
de menos 343 y esto lo que significa es
que estamos buscando un número que si lo
multiplicamos por sí mismo tres veces
porque la raíz cúbica entonces vamos a
obtener menos 343 y bueno eso también es
exactamente igual a tomar menos 343 y
elevarlo a la potencia un tercio ok y el
camino para encontrar esta raíz cúbica
es empezar por factorizar este número y
bueno aquí tenemos un menos entonces lo
primero que tenemos que factorizar es el
menos 1 y está menos 1
y el otro factor es 343 ahora 343 no es
divisible entre 2 porque es un número
impar no es divisible entre 3 porque 3 +
3 6 4 10 y 10 no es un múltiplo de 3
entonces este número no se puede dividir
entre 3 tampoco es un múltiplo de 4
porque sin par y no terminan en 5 ni en
0 así es que tampoco lo podemos dividir
entre 5 no lo podemos dividir entre 6
porque ni es múltiplo de dos niños
múltiplo de 3 entonces hay que ver si es
divisible entre 7 a ver vamos a hacerlo
por acá
43 será divisible entre 7 pues tenemos
que hacerlo a pata a ver el 7 cuántas
veces cabe dentro del 34 hoy es 7 por 5
35 entonces vamos a probar con 4 7 por 4
es 28 pero tenemos que restarlo
entonces nos queda 6 bajamos el 3
7 x 9 nos da 63
entonces nos queda de residuos 0 así es
que si 343 si es divisible entre 7 y se
factorizar como 7 por 49 y el 49 ya está
mucho más fácil porque seguro nos salta
a la vista que es un cuadrado perfecto
que es 7
7 entonces la factorización de menos 343
en sus factores primos es menos 17 7 y 7
así es que la raíz cúbica de menos 343
es exactamente igual a la raíz cúbica de
menos 1 por 7 por 7 por 7 y eso es igual
la raíz cúbica de menos 1
por la raíz cúbica de 7 por 7 por 7 ok
al igual que en las raíces cuadradas
porque las raíces cúbicas no son más que
elevar el número de adentro a la
potencia un tercio y entonces se heredan
todas las propiedades de los exponentes
a ver pero aquí
este número de aquí es igual a menos 1
ok porque menos 1 al cubo es igual a
menos 1 si quieres lo podemos verificar
menos 1 x menos 1 x menos 1 esto es
igual a menos 1 porque menos 1 x menos 1
es un 1 y 1 pero menos 1 es igual a
menos uno entonces si tomamos menos 1 y
lo multiplicamos por si mismo tres veces
osea lo elevamos al cubo nos queda menos
1 así es que la raíz cúbica de menos 1
es igual a menos 1 bueno
la raíz cúbica de 7 por 7 por 7 es 7
porque si tomamos este 7 y lo
multiplicamos por sí mismo 3 veces nos
queda 7 por 7 por 7 y eso es justo lo
que es la raíz cúbica buscar algún
número que si lo multiplicamos por sí
mismo
3 veces nos quede lo de adentro entonces
esto de aquí es igual a menos 7 que la
raíz cúbica de menos 343 es igual a
menos 7